pour les peintres
c'est la plus grande toile du monde et
ils s'en donnent à coeur joie
côté ouest les messages d'amitié et
d'amour finissent par humaniser le
rempart de béton
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
depuis à peu près maintenant bientôt
trois ans avec kerry noir on a eu l'idée
et d'autres utiliser cette idée
travailler cette pince ses murs eu
triche de mur de berlin
[Musique]
nous avons fait ça pour rappeler aux
gens que le mur existe comme un
empaquetage parce que les gens de passe
tous les jours tous les jours et ils
oublient que ce mur existe
[Musique]
un vieux rêve c'est pouvoir peindre le
mur de berlin
les peintres les enfants afa les
habitants autour de berlin puisse
s'exprimer sur ce mur et dire ce qu'ils
en pensent
[Musique]
pour la première fois ce matin à berlin
est des artistes et autres tagueurs ont
pu avec l'autorisation de la police
décorer le mur de berlin
de leur côté à eux
[Musique]
c'est merveilleux que ce mur ne soit
plus gris qu'il soit vert ou bleu qu'il
est toutes les couleurs
[Musique]